You asked me to have a blood draw in a month. I just ordered the female tumor marker panel. I'm just wondering what all will be assessed by memory is failing me.
Well, I'd have to look at it as well, but the female tumor marker panel is testing five tumor markers most commonly seeded with with the female tumors.
I think it's CA 53, CA 99, CA 125, CEA and one other one.
That's different than the male tumor panel, male tumor marker panel, which would also include PSA, maybe not the 53.
So, yeah, it's not testing for it's not a CBC, which is a complete one called it's not a complete metabolic panel. So that would be different. So you'd have to order that just well if we want to look at those things.
I'm a measure of a glucose and it remains higher than we'd like it to be the lowest. I've been able to get it to 87 very frustrated because I've cut out all honey, maple syrup, also trying to minimize fruit, increased meat, still doing a lot of vegetables, as much organic as possible, the only process foods.
I do our occasional gluten free better pasta. I do eat some rice for a starch lately more potatoes than I should. Thanks so much.
Yeah, it's, it's, you know, people think that I'm just going to, you know, reduce glucose out of my diet, my glucose is going to come down. Well, anybody that has has diabetes understands it's just not that simple.
So reducing glucose is the start, but your cell membranes healing, how damaged are your cell membranes, how healthy is your pancreas.
You know, all this plays a role and it takes time for those things to heal. So you just got to be patient with yourself. What's that?
What are said tied to your diet?